elle m'a dit tu dormes épicier la aux
clients vous a merdé pas la vie ça fait
demi heure que j'attends devant votre
cagna d'épicerie là qu'est ce qui se
passe et je faisais la sieste quand
abadie tu dors le 6h15 l'aleba deux mois
ceux-ci s'en remet à quai ce 6 ans vous
voulez suivre en live web en nature
fossé avec et soyez polis la prière de
morrison nature ne parle plus et nature
vous voulez le report on complète marvin
air hockey canada au 2 mai camembert
allez hop ça ira plus vite avec les
asticots sans les asticots world records
il va me faire revenir la transpiration
mais j'ose même pas lui demander le jus
d'orange
il va me demander avec les bulls a les
bus je n'ai plus
c'est pas plus mal var ont gagné du
temps comme ça allez vous mettez une
petite bière et la bière je vous de la
grotte tambour une photo de groupe comme
du paquet de six attaques à 2 12 aux
flashs de corps ou écoutez moi bien je
voudrais du ver rouge de préférence le
vais vous le groupe et dans une
bouteille voyez avec une étiquette
collée avec de la colle alors j je peux
plus là à vous énerver je donne ma
bouteille une étiquette collée avec la
colle royalement la bouteille beauté un
vert bouteille plastique on les petits
commerces alors vous plaignez toute
l'année que vous n'êtes plus de pognon
et plus de clients il faut voir pose est
devenu un maire d'arles et voilà tout ça
parce que hier je les battues à la
pétanque
aujourd'hui il se croyait le nerfs en
boule
bon puisque vous taper des pieds je vous
la laisse un moment je suis bien arrivé
à la guerre hier on a tiré les rois
c'est moi que la sphère et mesurait 10
cm de long et elle a pénétré très
profondément dans mon bras gauche après
l'opération j'ai bu du champagne
ça pique j'ai cassé ma montre n'a ma
mère aveugle et il me reste plus que la
petite aiguille ça ne me gêne pas trop
mais je redoute que quelqu'un me demande
lol on est passé par mr dame non le port
ya des marins qui change et qui puisse
relativement fort de préférence sur des
femmes infidèles par les invite à
monsieur le curé mais ne lui dites
surtout pas que c'est moi qui ai cafter
plus ces moments que ici je trouve plein
de champignons comme je suis souvent à
plat ventre je les vois plus facilement
mais il va falloir que j'arrête de
gratter la terre avec mon fusil sa
bouche le canon il n'est pas méchant le
capitaine mais il crie très fort
l'autre jour il s'est vraiment fâché
très très fort je suis allé directement
de prison je ne suis pas passé par la
case départ
je n'ai même pas reçu vingt deux mille
j'ai eu six mois de cachot c'est loin de
cachot ça paraît long mais j'ai trouvé
une combine en dormant 12 est 13 heures
par jour je n'ai fait que trois mois
effectifs au pour noël
mon copain a eu des biscuits moi j'ai eu
une bronchite
on m'a volé mes chaussures que j'avais
laissé aux cris d' un sapin ici on ne
peut faire confiance à personne
on est très mal entouré en fait on est
complètement encerclées dit à mon frère
il arrête de m'envoyer des packs r&d
collet vu au début je trouvais ça drôle
à présent mes nerfs lâchent un petit peu
le général vient de nous annoncer que
nous serions tous rapidement exterminer
de regarder le mot exterminés dans le
dictionnaire et mende mais assez
efficace ion exact répond moi le plus
vite possible
à propos des factures de gaz
d'électricité que tu trouves tu cher je
te signale que le montant à payer est
inscrit dans une case à droite de la
quittance depuis trois ans occupait la
date
c'est pour ça que ça a tendance à
augmenter tous les jours signé ton petit
euro vi t'aime très fort
mesdames mezzo hamel mes vieux bienvenue
à radio chant et beasley j'entends des
gens qui rient sol alors je vous
préviens tout de suite je vends dans
aucun fruit
pendant ma circonférence je veux pouvoir
entendre le viol d'une mouche j'aurais
qui répète depuis de méduses ah bah
ouais si monsieur de tours équipe était
le membre y seule personne mais croûte
je répète depuis le début d'un côté si
tout le monde sans flou heureusement
flou offrit côté je vous en prie je vous
en free soyez un petit peu attentif
certaines personnes ont des problèmes
énormes de prononciation aph les
affligés bouzat fluhr si je vous le dis
c'est le nez de sur ce mur je récupère
bien depuis le début ça rigole encore
vous savez que vous est insupportable
j'ai l'impression que je parle dans le
vide à force d'en m'interrompez témoin
je vais finir par me rouiller
j'aurais québec depuis levés du bon
alors là moi j'en ai plein le fur j'ai
l'impression que tout ce que je vous
explique ça vous intéresse pas mais faut
mais croûte et ouvrir les orteils
je répète depuis le début du mois et
coûté maintenant salsifis
je vous le dis salsifis maintenant le
premier grisolles le fou mon choix c'est
la piqûre
j'aurais québec depuis de méduses
c'est ça frier frier on verra bien qui
c'est qui frisera le dernier c'est ça
prenait mois pour un indélébile je
récupère mais depuis le bidule bon si
c'est comme ça je récupère du salut
alors les jeunes ça va on va c'est
gentil devenu voir pp pour son
anniversaire
et oui j'ai 99 ans et je pète le feu
j'ai au moins 50 ans devant moi et j'ai
décidé d'en profiter parce que je viens
de m'apercevoir qu'en 99 ans j'ai perdu
tout mon temps j'ai rien tant en dormant
huit heures par jour j'ai calculé que
dans ma vie j'ai roupiller pendant 33
ans
en plus j'ai perdu au moins six mois de
ma vie et c'est de faire démarrer ma
voiture
les pousser pendant au moins un an et
demi et j'ai mis deux ans pour la
revendre et un tout petit déjeuner dans
ma vie j'ai calculé que je me suis tapé
700000 dakine de pas avec deux tonnes de
beurre en 99 en fumant trois paquets de
cigarettes par jour j'ai calculé que
j'ai avalé 800 kg de nicotine et trois
tonnes de goudron le boire grenier
l'autoroute paris marseille et dans les
oui incroyable
rien qu'en regardant la télévision trois
heures tous les jours j'ai calculé que
dans ma vie je suis resté 12 ans devant
la télé 12 ans assis le cul dans un
fauteuil à tripoter les boutons
dont six mois entier passer devant le
panneau veuillez nous excuser de ce
merdier momentanée incroyable tant qu'on
peut perdre avec ces petites conneries
un éclatant faire pipi c'est rien du
tout
cinq minutes tous les jours et bien 99
ans j'ai calculé que j'ai pissé pendant
les 2 mais un homme est enfermé dans les
toilettes
même en prison ils sont mieux en plus
d'air je te dis pas le temps que j'ai
perdu à faire des petits câlins d'amour
avec ma mémé nador et un petit câlin par
ci un petit câlin par là en 99 ans je me
suis tapé 92 miller de taille azzouz et
franchement je me sens encore bien petit
quart d'heure supplémentaire